and you've got this service read book
the all the figures in it I mean it
overall is he given more than he's taken
well that's I mean that's always the big
question because you know there's lots
of sound and fury but what does it
actually amount it i'll just going to
quickly show you i mean this this pie
chart as it were shows you precisely
what the Chancellor is going to be
spending money on and you can see the
vast majority the biggest chunk of that
right hand side social protection that's
welfare and that really is why this
comes back down to why he was talking
about a welfare cap he needs to try to
bring that down or bring that under
control and that is one of the you know
ongoing themes but you asked whether you
know is this actually a big spending
moment a big tax moment i'm going to
show you something called the school
card now this is essentially all of the
sums that the government has done in
advance of this budget okay and i know
it looks a little bit complicated but
i'm going to get just kind of briefly
show you a few things that underline
precisely what kind of a budget this was
was it a big fiscal moment or was it not
this is the second page of the school
code i'm just going to circle something
for you here it's the line talking about
total policy decisions now you see those
numbers those up those are millions of
pounds and the rule of thumb is if
you're talking about thousands of
millions of pounds in other words
billions that's a big budget you know
that means that you are either putting a
lot of money in out into the economy or
taking it out through tax increases and
you can see from looking at this it's
pretty neutral it's a giveaway in the
first few years and it's taking money
back afterwards and i just want to show
you what the biggest things were here
what actually accounted for the main
increase in the main changes there and
as you can see it's the personal
allowance it is that change that
increase which results in quite a big
giveaway you can see money going out
there whereas when it comes to the icin
we talked about all these pension
reforms remember that was a big part of
this sweet nonetheless when you're
looking here these are relatively small
numbers savings tax not going to cost
that much bringing in the higher limits
Isis
makes a big flurry but it doesn't
necessarily cost that much so actually
when you look through the numbers here
we're not talking about massive sums
we're talking about quite small binner
that comes down to the fact that
although the economic numbers are a bit
better than expected it's not like
there's an enormous amount of money left
to spend well can you shed any light on
this issue of who does best out of this
budget where there is those of the
richer end of society or at the poor end
we've had that increase in the in the
personal allowance this rate of which
the level at which you start paying
income tax but yet then you know richer
people are liking our bigger pensions
and more saving that's all my other
screen but hope but like we can show you
know we can basically show you that the
number of people who are paying the
higher rate of tax has gone up
considerably it's gone up about 1.4
million over the course of the last four
years alone the the fact though remains
that you have to bear in mind personal
allowances if you get a bit more cash
tax free from your earnings then it
means you don't necessarily pay as much
on that as well so the promise the
machaon slew is that that will feed in
and although you may be paying a higher
rate of tax you will be getting a bit
more of it tax-free at the store and so
when everything nets out you might be a
little bit better off that's the theory